l'ordre du jour appelle les explications
de vote des groupes et le vote par
scrutin public ordinaire sur le projet
de loi relatifs à la différenciation la
décentralisation la déconcentration et
portant diverses mesures de
simplification de l'action publique
locale et la parole est à madame cécile
cukierman pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes pour
sept minutes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame sueur à porter mais mes
chers collègues nous arrivons
effectivement en fin de parcours
d'études de ce texte est tout d'abord je
veux le redire dans des conditions de
travail législatif qui ne sont pas
satisfaisants tant par son calendrier
d'inscription temps sur les délais que
nous avons eues y compris entre le
travail en commissions et l'examen en
séance avec un texte qui inévitablement
et parce qu'il a été travaillé a vu son
nombre d'articles y compris presque
doublé entre la commission et le passage
en séance et donc nous ne pouvons que
regretter ce travail un peu poussif
jusque dans les derniers jours de cette
session extraordinaire pour pouvoir
finir ce texte qui pour autant répond et
doit répondre aux attentes des
collectivités territoriales un texte
mais je l'avais déjà dit dans
l'intervention général qui à nos yeux
manque toujours de souffle manque de
souffle
or il ya inévitablement une urgence
démocratique qui nous est rappelé bien
évidemment avec l'abstention galopante
scrutin après scrutin mais plus
largement et je crois nous voyons est
compris dans nos débats de société
aujourd'hui dans une défiance finalement
entre les citoyens et les élus entre
justement ce qui devrait aller
représenter et d'un pacte de confiance
d'impact politique qui se dire est ce
qu'il est jour après jour nous avons
également
regretter parce que il y as besoin je le
disais de redonner du sens mais il ya
surtout cette nécessité à renforcer les
moyens pour permettre aux élus les côtes
aux élus locaux pardon de répondre plus
mieux et davantage aux besoins de leurs
de leur population
je ne vais pas répéter ce que nous avons
dit ici pendant plusieurs heures mais re
dire très simplement que à nos yeux la
clause de compétence générale pour
toutes les collectivités territoriales
demeure encore aujourd'hui la seule
garantie d'une simplification réel d'une
simplification démocratique et d'une
simplification qui assure justement
cette fameuse décentralisation dont
notre république d'ailleurs se défini
dès son article premier et al'inverse
j'aurais envie de dire du renfort de
cette véritable décentralisation et bien
vous nous avez proposé la
différenciation qui après l'examen des
différents articles demeure toujours à
nos yeux source très certainement pour
les mois et les années qui viennent
d'une complexité un peu plus importante
d'une remise en cause d'un certain
nombre de principes d' équilibre entre
des missions régaliennes et le pouvoir
local mais surtout très certainement le
renforcement et la satisfaction
d'ailleurs que l'on peut lire le
renforcement un certain nombre de
collectivités territoriales que l'on
qualifie parfois des grandes
collectivités territoriales et donc
inévitablement dans les années à venir
un renforcement d'une concurrence entre
les collectivités alors que nous aurions
besoin et ce n'est pas simple de
renforcer et d'assurer de garantir
l'égalité entre toutes les collectivités
territoriales sur la déconcentration et
donc la place de l'état qui demeure
indispensable
vous me permettrez madame la ministre de
dire qu'elle demeure très superficielle
certes il y a eu après les travaux du
sénat
un renfort notamment de la présence
départemental de l'état au détriment
d'une presse d'un pouvoir parfois
régionales cependant la déconcentration
ne peut se résumer par un renfort du
pouvoir des préfets une véritable
déconcentration pour garantir une
décentralisation passe inévitablement
par une présence renforcée multiplier
des agents de l'état dans leurs
différents métiers pour venir justement
en soutien et en appui aux élus locaux
et leur permettre de répondre à leurs
exigences du de leur mandat pour comme
je le disais répondre aux besoins des
populations
c'est finalement donc un texte aux
nombreux sujets nous avons parlé des
grands enjeux de décentralisation
différenciation je disais de la question
de la politique du logement jusqu'à
celle de l'alignement des arbres en tout
cas c'est effectivement un texte qui
inévitablement et je ne le dis avec
aucune ironie ni mépris a permis de
répondre à de nombreux soucis de
nombreuses problématiques parfois plus
ou moins local mais en tout cas des
soucier des problématiques du quotidien
et ça sur cette partie là en tout cas
nous l'acton mais nous nous serons bien
évidemment très vigilants aux suites et
un certain nombre d'évolutions parce que
madame la ministre je sais que c'est une
expression aujourd'hui très à la mode
mais le cousu main ne peut pas toujours
faire lois de la république
surtout comme je disais à l'heure où il
me semble mais je crois que nous sommes
d'ailleurs plusieurs à le partager ici
même si c'est parfois avec des réponses
différentes
il y à une urgence aujourd'hui non pas
simplement à faire du cousu main mais à
répondre à ces aspirations des
populations des élus locaux de nos
collectivités territoriales pour
garantir en respectant bien évidemment
les différences des uns et des autres
qui sont je le redis avant tout une
richesse mais qui en les respectant et
en faisant république nous permettront
d'avoir une
un avenir en commun en tout cas plus
apaisé que celui qui se présente
aujourd'hui je veux pour finir souligné
un certain nombre d'évolutions à nos
yeux en tout cas positive bien
évidemment l'amélioration de la
possibilté de la saisine par les
présidents des chambres du conseil
d'évaluation des normes la prise en
compte de l'évaluation de la
compensation pour les nouvelles
compétences transférées et bien
évidemment la volonté réaffirmée ici au
sénat de la possibilité offerte aux
communes au sein des intercommunalités
concernées de maintenir la compétence
eau et assainissement pouvoir communal
la question n'est pas d'être
misérabilisme ni de faire du commune du
communalisme mais bien au contraire je
crois dans cet esprit de la
décentralisation de maintenir dans la
proximité autant que faire possible tout
ce qui peut être géré et qui est plutôt
bien géré pour répondre aux besoins de
nos populations
finalement et j'en finirai ainsi malgré
tous ces débats la différenciation à nos
yeux n'est pas la décentralisation
démocratique indispensable cette
décentralisation qui doit garantir les
libertés locales tout en garantissant lé
gard et l'égalité républicaine entre
chacune et chacun et j'aurais envie de
dire sans surprise nous voterons contre
ce texte
merci la parole est à mme françoise
gatel pour le groupe union centriste
pour sept minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois que
je tiens à remercier pour nous avoir
accompagnés et soutenus et encouragés
pendant ce texte
permettez-moi aussi avant de vous saluer
mes chers collègues rapporteur et et
autres d'avoir un message de gratitude
et de remerciement pour l'équipe des
administrateurs de la commission des
lois qui ont fourni un travail
considérable dans des conditions
accélérée des riaux madame la ministre
vous connaissez sûrement y riffs iris et
la messagère des dieux grecs qui étaient
alors adoré je vois que monsieur le
directeur de la dgcl connaît iris elle
était adorée de tous parce qu'elle
n'apportait que des bonnes nouvelles
eh bien vous voici madame la ministre
l'iris du sénat si je puis dire puisque
vous allez porter au gouvernement et à
l'assemblée de très bonnes nouvelles sur
un texte que nous avons grâce à vous pu
travailler grâce à vous dans un dialogue
constructif construit je crois d'une
manière très positive soyez en remerciés
puisque notre objectif c'est
l'efficacité de l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et jusqu'au
dernier nos concitoyens alors de quoi
s'agissait-il dans dans ce texte parfois
nous at on dit un texte barbare un peu
techno faible d'une timidité excessive
nous même avons dit parfois eu ceci en
tout cas encore une fois joué au jeu
vous renouvelle mes remerciements pour
nous avoir amené ce texte de crise forte
et line social avec les gilet jaune et
l'autre sanitaires psychologiques et
même économiques bouleverse et puis-je
notre pays mais ont aussi montré sa
capacité à tenir dans des temps un peu
fort grâce à l'engagement à lasalle et
responsable des élus locaux quand l'état
était à leurs côtés à l'heure des crises
tirons les leçons et iront les vite
parce que nous sentons que notre pays
est un peu comme le temps orageux et
impétueux alors certains d'entre nous
auraient rêvé
d'un grand soir de l'organisation
territoriale mais les grands soirs étant
parfois suivi de petits matins blêmes
nous avons pensé que ce n'est peut-être
pas la voix et le sénat n'a pas manqué
d'audace je crois ni d'ambition cas nous
avons choisi notre ligne de conduite un
nouveau big bang territorial qui serait
un peu hasardeuses comme nous en avons
connus nous avons préféré une révolution
des esprits ce qui n'est pas rien celle
de l'agilité de la souplesse de la
confiance dans les élus locaux et celle
d'un état régalien mais aussi très
présent dans les territoires
facilitateur pour l'action des élus
alors pour construire nos travaux appuyé
sur les 50 propositions du sénat
l'adhésion de trois cent mille deux
cents élus qui ont répondu à notre
consultation de son parti tout
simplement des besoins des élus est
proposée contrairement à cet esprit
français cartésien de la norme nous
avons proposé un champ des possibles qui
permette qui donne des solutions aux
élus selon un principe de subsidiarité
il faut que celui qui est le mieux placé
face les choses
ainsi madame la ministre nous avons
adoré la décentralisation et vous avez
vu vous avez vu comment nous avons
poussé un peu les feux parce que comment
pouvons nous assurer la protection des
enfants si ce qui détecte les problèmes
à l'école je parle de la médecine
scolaire ne parle pas à ceux qui ont les
solutions et les responsabilités les
départements il en est de même pour les
pour les cantines de lycée et madame la
mini jeux vous avoue que j'ai été
subjugué par la fois l'extravagance que
vous nous avez proposé puisque vous nous
proposez pour les gestionnaires de l'iss
et d'expérimenter une potentielle
convention entre le lycée et le
présidente départements et des régions
qui permettrait si le directeur
d'établissement veux bien que le
président de la collectivité pourra
éventuellement parler si ceci si celui
ci le veut bien aux gestionnaires
de de cantine et de lycées sauf que ces
conventions est inventée en 2004 au
moment du transfert des tos donc vingt
ans après nous proposer une timide deux
expérimentations
disons que c'est un peu c'est un peu
extravagant madame la même et je ne
doute pas qu encourager par nos soins
nous irons nous irons un petit peu plus
loin enfin madame la ministre nous avons
beaucoup aimé la différenciation
l'article 1 du texte a même été reconnue
comme fin par le conseil d'état ce qui
n'est pas rien donc nous fidèles
serviteurs de l'action publique et de
son intérêt nous avons nourri ce texte
un peu faible et nous pensons que la
différenciation qui n'est pas la
déstructuration de la république mais au
contraire la prise en compte du réel
pour mieux servir nos concitoyens et
garantir l'égalité des droits
nous l'avons conjugués et angie et je
sais que vous avez à dents et ça madame
la ministre parce que nous avons
introduit la territorialisation des
compétences nous avons réaffirmé
l'enjeu de délégations de compétence
d'une collectivité à une autre et enfin
madame la ministre nous avons reparlé de
l'intérêt communautaire cas celui qui
arrivera à nous convaincre du
rayonnement metropolitan danic poule
sincèrement moi je l'attends
je l'attends encore et madame la
ministre vous n'êtes pas si loin de nous
sur le fond parce que dans l'amendement
que vous est proposée sur aix marseille
provence vous nous faites de l'intérêt
communautaire comme c'est journal
faisait de la prose sans savoir vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi mais je
maintiens que sur ce sujet madame la
ministre je n'ai pas tort madame la
ministre je pense très sincèrement qu'il
faut que nous puissions par la souplesse
l'agilité que nous avons donnée au lieu
d'une l'homme replacer l'état
déconcentré au coeur dé la gestion des
problèmes en proximité replacer aussi
les élus locaux qui ont montré leur
efficacité et le binôme état
collectivités qui essentielle on l'a vu
pendant la crise dont madame la ministre
vous avez choisi la crise
pardon excusez moi pas la crise vous
avez vous avez choisi la procédure
d'urgence dans urgences il ya le mot
urgence ça veut sans doute dire que vous
êtes convaincus de la nécessité d'aller
vite et qu'en tout cas on compte sur
vous pour être la messagère de la
prospérité d'un texte jusqu'à
l'assemblée nationale ce qui semble un
peu douteux et surtout que nous
réussissions parce qu'il ya urgence à
agir madame laminé il s'agit pas d'un
texte de techno mais il s'agit de servir
nos concitoyens et de retrouver leur
confiance
merci à vous madame la ministre merci la
parole est à monsieur éric kerrouche
pour le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains et pour sept minutes chers
collègues nama présidente madame la
ministre mesdames messieurs les
rapporteurs que dire de ce texte et
comment le qualifier
si c'était un livre j'hésite entre la
peau de chagrin ou au vu du texte
initial et le portrait de dorian gray au
vu de ce qu'il est devenu
si c'était une poésie ce serait
forcément l'inventaire de jacques
prévert
si c'était un animal ce serait une
méduse ou toutes autres invertébrés si
c'était une peinture ce serait bien
entendu un collage si c'était un jeu
j'hésite entre un puzzle ou si on est
plus sévère
les échecs et voilà 80 458 217 ce n'est
pas une suite mathématiques c'est le
nombre d'articles que compte désormais
le texte 3ds au terme d'un examen long
fastidieux décousu au cours duquel rien
ne nous aura été épargné tant sur la
forme réserve intempestives d'articles
mitage de l'examen jusqu'à une seconde
délibération assez incongru hier soir
que sur le fond le texte initial et le
péché originel
vous êtes connu madame la ministre pour
être expert de notre système local et
pour avoir fait progresser celui-ci par
de multiples initiatives
quel contraste avec le texte que vous
avez proposé alors qu'il portait une
grande ambition de grandes annonces à
la crise des gilets jaunes les
conditions baroque de son examen résulte
de sa nature originelle il a été
d'autant plus facilement tordu par la
majorité sénatoriale qu'il n'avait pas
de colonne vertébrale ce texte mal n'est
ce texte nids-de-poule a été achevée par
la droite sénatoriale
après deux ans de concertation le texte
est une liste d'une liste de mesures qui
ne tire pas d'enseignements de la crise
sanitaire démocratique sociale que nous
traversons et ne répond pas aux attentes
d'élus locaux qui quand ils ne sont pas
déçus sont indifférents au delà des
correctifs mineurs pour certains utile
ce projet de loi comporte et pour nous
fiset cueille d'abord une
différenciation qui constitue une cible
ratée une décentralisation tron
résiduelles une déconcentration qui
s'assimile plus à une recentralisation
une simplification complexifie catrice
un comble un traitement lacunaire de la
question des ressources financières et
en dessert l'ignorance totale de la
question démocratique alors qu'elle
aurait dû selon nous à être une
composante majeure
bref ce texte n'apportait pas énormément
c'était juste une déception eu égard aux
attentes avec beaucoup de petites
disposition mais pas grand chose sur
l'essentiel le texte sorti du sénat ne
tient plus lui de la samba un pas en
avant deux pas en arrière
alors il ya eu des petits pas l'examen
par le sénat a permis quelques avancées
que nous partageons avec les rapporteurs
et oui chères françoise gatel cher
mathieu darnaud tout arrive et que nous
avions également proposé compétences des
régions en matière d'emploi
d'apprentissage et de formation
professionnelle transfert à la carte des
compétences facultatives au sein des
opci renforcement des pouvoirs
réglementaires des régions dans
l'attribution de certaines subventions
et n après avoir évité les nombreuses
irrecevabilité une quinzaine de nos
amendements ont été adoptés comme
l'obligation de réponse pour le premier
ministre aux propositions d'adaptation
législative qui lui ferait du bien y
compris d'ailleurs pendant les questions
au gouvernement
accord des communes à la majorité
qualifiée en cas de délégation des
comptes
d'un opci extension à l'ensemble des
départements frontaliers des compétences
qui sont d'ores et déjà reconnue pour la
collectivité européenne d'alsace
rétablissement auquel nous tenions de
l'expérimentation de la recentralisation
du rsa expérimentation pour développer
un système de transport sur d'anciennes
voies ferrées mais mais ils y allaient
grand pas en arrière
il ya tout le reste les franchissements
de lignes rouges par la majorité
sénatoriale qui font selon nous
régresser ce texte dans toutes ses
facettes
la ligne éditoriale et est connue de
longue date et elle tient lieu de
posture haro sur l'intercommunalité
culpabilisation et stigmatisation des
plus précaires mise à l'écart de la
démocratie locale sur l'intercommunalité
c'est que le début sur
l'intercommunalité en s'appuyant sur une
défense bontin des libertés locales la
majorité sénatoriale porte des
propositions peu réaliste alors que les
opci incarne un espace de coopération
nécessaire aux politiques publiques
ils sont systématiquement opposée aux
communes qui leur doivent pourtant une
partie de leur salut
c'est probablement parce que nous avons
un désaccord de fond sur le principe de
solidarité que nous ne comprenons pas
cette valorisation du repli sur soi
c'est également pour cette raison qu'à
la délégation de compétence tous azimuts
nous préférons la coopération inter
territoriales
la majorité sénatoriale a ainsi fait le
choix de revenir sur l'intérêt
communautaire par exemple en matière de
zones d'activités alors qu'elles
constituent le coeur des compétences
intercommunales ou pour encore une fois
remettre en cause la solution trouvée en
matière d'eau et d'assainissement sans
même s'interroger
ça aurait été une solution sur une
possibilité ici opportune de
différenciation territoriale la majorité
territoriale est également toujours plus
forte avec les faibles conditions de
patrimoine pour l'attribution du rsa
affectation de la paix de la pch à
d'autres charges tentative d'amodiation
de la loi sru même si il est vrai elles
ont été contenus par la rapporteure en
ce qui concerne le rsa certaine
expression entendue dans cet hémicycle
comme celle de rente gagnerait à
disparaître des comptes rendus en
détournant les possibilités liées aux
pouvoirs réglementaires locales
à droite sénatoriale a atteint 2
objectif décrédibiliser le principe de
différenciation et stigmatiser les plus
précaires
le pouvoir réglementaire doit permettre
de faire mieux ou plus pas de raboter
les droits sociaux ou les politiques
volontaristes en matière écologique
dans le même ordre d'idée l'article 50
rands est finalement possible les
échanges de données pour lutter contre
les non recours aux droits sociaux que
le groupe socialiste avait déjà proposé
en juin
vous avez préféré cantonné ces
dispositions à une information du
bénéficiaire plutôt qu'à une application
de ces droits
c'était pourtant une mesure de
simplification et une faculté dead pour
les plus précaires c'était sans doute un
peu trop pour eux
enfin en matière de démocratie locale et
de participation tout a été relégué sur
ce sujet quand l'exécutif est
constamment dans la stratégie de
l'évitement la majorité sénatoriale
elle est aux abonnés absents la
démocratie représentative ne peut rester
ne peut rester exclusif de toute autre
forme de participation le temps de la
démocratie éclipse a vécu nous avons
donc voulu en dépit des nombreuses
irrecevabilité comme sur la parité
proposer des solutions qui deviendront
des solutions d'avenir
quand bien même elle poserait des
contrats aux élus parce qu'elles feront
vivre la démocratie locale
pour toutes ces raisons refus de
solidarité territoriale remise en cause
de la question sociale négation de la
démocratie locale
nous voterons bien sûr contre ce texte
merci
la parole est à monsieur stéphane ravier
pour 3 minutes
madame la présidente mandana ministre
mes chers collègues la montagne 3ds aura
accouché d'une souris
la date choisie pour la décentralisation
n'étant pas la commune
votre projet de loi n'entraîne aucun
changement de structure d'efficacité et
de représentativité des français vous
n'avez fait que mélanger le jeu de
cartes mais le château de cartes
reconstituer toujours le même une
citadelle imprenable dans laquelle les
élus sont barricadés à laquelle les
citoyens peuvent très difficilement
accéder en intérieur on s'y perd quant à
jean labyrinthe aucune amélioration
prévue en matière de consultation
citoyenne les choix territoriaux se font
sans l'aval des intéressés il manque à
ce texte
le quatrième des deux démocraties de
plus le contrat de mixité sociale fixant
les objectifs de logements sociaux à
atteindre est signée entre le maire le
président de le pci et le préfet le
maire et donc minoritaire pour décider
de la politique d'habitat et de logement
sur son propre territoire
de quoi accentuer le sentiment de
dépossession des élus locaux et des
habitants
faire un grand défenseur des valeurs
républicaines de la mixité sociale vont
devoir passer de la théorie du vivre
ensemble à la réalité du livre avec je
leur souhaite beaucoup de courage et
d'abnégation républicaine les maires ne
sont ne semble pas vraiment au centre de
l'attention du parlement puisque la
commission mixte paritaire du projet de
loi puma et résilience laurent refuser
un droit de veto sur tout projet éolien
envisagé sur leur commune j'espère que
cette disposition rajoutée à nouveau
dans ce texte sera maintenu à terme
en ce qui concerne plus particulièrement
la métropole aix marseille provence
les sénateurs de la majorité de droite
ont descendu leurs baronnies
métropolitaine en laissant bon seigneur
quelques miettes aux 92 communes qui la
composent
mais en laissant bien mais en rappelant
bien que les compétences déléguées
devait rester sous la coupe souveraine
de sa présidente martine vassal des
méthodes porter analystes bien loin du
principe de libre administration des
communes qui ne deviennent que des
relais de la métropole et dans
l'autonomie est définitivement une
histoire du passé
rien sur le pays d'arles rien sur le c
29 communes bucco rhodanienne qui
résiste à l'autre métropolitain qu'elle
soit assurer de mon soutien dans leur
résistance à l'oppression de
l'intégration de force
oui citoyens aisés et les élus locaux
ont été chamboulées par les lois rct
notre aimable tome mais il faudra à
l'avenir m courageusement des choses à
l'endroit en s'appuyant sur le triptyque
communes département et à celles à la
clé d'une vraie différenciation
décentralisation déconcentration
simplification la liberté et la fubicy
diaries t sont nécessaires au respect
des identités et à l'efficacité de
l'action publique pour nos mères premier
représentant est premier acteur de
l'état décentralisé il ne restera qu'un
dé celui et pour rester polie de la
débrouille des commines des communes les
plus rurales aux communes urbaines
petite et moyenne chaque crise est gérée
selon le système d et ce texte n'y
changera rien cependant et pour conclure
je voterai en faveur de ce petit texte
pour appuyer les quelques possibilité
introduite sur le renforcement du
contrôle par le pour le versement du rsa
sur les délégations de compétence des
métropoles vers les communes sur la
libre autonomie municipale en matière
d'éolien en espérant car je reste
l'éternel optimiste que l'assemblée
nationale jouera pas les godillots du
gouvernement en cassant ses apports
souhaité par les élus locaux
merci jeux sont pris la parole est à
monsieur stéphane le rudulier pour le
groupe les républicains font sept
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues nous terminons
aujourd'hui deux semaines de travaux
parlementaires particulièrement intenses
sur ce projet de loi consacré à la
différenciation la décentralisation et
la déconcentration et autant dire que le
sujet était vaste et pourtant
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour du sénat
n'était pas une évidence au regard de
l'agenda particulièrement resserré de
nos travaux et je tiens en préambule
madame la ministre a salué votre ferme
résolution car vous êtes parvenu à faire
valoir aux yeux du gouvernement
l'important c'est la primauté de ses
sujets
malgré ces impératifs calendaires et
donc je m'adresse à avoue avec beaucoup
de respect et je me réjouis de votre
force de conviction par rapport au cadre
contraint qui vous a été fixé par le
premier ministre et le président de la
république
néanmoins force est de constater que le
texte initial n'était pas du tout à la
hauteur de ce que nous attendions alors
même qu'ils nous avait été présenté
comme le troisième acte majeur de la
décentralisation car madame la ministre
quelle était la véritable ligne
directrice de ce texte
sinon de savoir comment mettre fin au
jacobinisme excessif de ces quarante
dernières années qui ne cesse de
prospérer à travers notamment la
multiplication des normes l'organisation
de la dépendance financière des
collectivités et l'éloignement des
principaux centres décision de
territoire alors oui ce texte fut une
réelle déception pour notre famille
politique
car manquant d'ambition à bien des
égards car privilégions généralement les
mesures paramétrique
sous prétexte de simplification tout en
évitant de s'aventurer sur d'autres
terrains essentiels et en abordant de
multiples sujets trop varié kim aurait
mérité à eux seuls un projet de loin et
son examen de surcroît ce qui a d'autant
plus limité la portée du texte
c'est bien évidemment l'absence d'un
volet financier robuste indispensable à
une véritable décentralisation et à une
différenciation
alors pour autant le sénat ne s'est pas
résigné et c'est avec une ferme
attention de renaud des corps à ce
projet de loin que la haute assemblée a
débuté ses travaux
je voudrais saluer nos rapporteur qui se
sont efforcés d'insuffler un surprenant
mission est d'envergure à ce texte
je pense principalement la françoise
gatel et mathieu darnaud pour la
commission des lois mais également un
dominique estrosi sassone aux affaires
économiques
elle un million aux affaires sociales ou
encore daniel guéret pour le
développement durable
pour ce faire nous nous sommes appuyés
sur les réflexions antérieure de l'autre
chambre
je pense notamment aux fameuses 50
propositions du sénat sous la direction
du président larcher remise en juillet
dernier au président de la république et
au gouvernement et qui sont
malheureusement restées lettre morte et
plus récemment un rapport d'information
de nos collègues estrosi sassone et
l'état consacré à la loi sru
ainsi le texte des commissions
présentait déjà un certain nombre
d'avancées
je n'ai pas faire l'inventaire exhaustif
de l'ensemble des apports du sénat mais
chouette néanmoins m'arrêter sur
quelques mesures phares et notamment
celles visant à garantir la possibilité
d'un exercice différencier des
compétences au sein du bloc communal par
le biais du transfert à la carte de
compétence ou encore la suppression du
caractère obligatoire du transfert des
compétences eau et assainissement et
gestion des eaux pluviales urbaines
ou bien encore la consécration du
principe selon lequel toute décision
prise à l'échelle territoriale relève
prioritairement du préfet du département
ces dispositions viennent parfaire le
volet différenciation et des
concentrations de ce projet de loi et
sur le sujet ô combien sensible du
logement le sénat a adopté des mesures
visant à permettre une meilleure
conciliation entre l'action des
collectivités et la réalisation des
objectifs de la loi dite sru avec la
prolongation de ce dispositif sans date
butoir et en rattrapage glissant la mise
en place d'un rattrapage différencier
contractualiser via un contrat de mixité
sociale dont le maire et le préfet
serait la cheville ouvrière ouvrante
ainsi une démarche partenariale
permettant de sortir de ce climat que je
qualifierais de défiance qui s'étaient
installés depuis plusieurs années entre
l'état et les communes carencé ou
déficitaires en dernier lieu la
suppression de sanctions inefficace et
contreproductive pour initier un système
de fléchage des éventuelles pénalités de
carence vers la construction de
logements sur volet sanitaire et sociale
j'évoquerai la réforme de la gouvernance
des ars qui se veut plus équilibrée à
l'égard des élus locaux
laissant notamment la place à une co
présidence du préfet de région et du
président du conseil régional
enfin permettez moi en tant que sénateur
des bouches du rhône de souligner tout
particulièrement le consensus auquel
nous avons abouti hier soir au sujet de
cette fameuse métropole aix marseille
dont l'action et l'efficacité sont mises
à mal depuis cinq ans du fait
principalement d'une mauvaise
répartition des compétences entre les
différents niveaux et j'insiste sur ce
fait qu'en revenant l'esprit originel de
l'intercommunalité il s'agit je pense
d'un véritable tournant historique qui
va permettre de rendre la parole
aux élus locaux afin de définir ce
nouveau cadre institutionnel et je
voudrais saluer une nouvelle fois la
qualité du dialogue que nous avons eues
avec madame la ministre sur ce sujet
aussi essentiel pour le quotidien de 1,8
million d'habitants
enfin en outre tous ces apports en
commission de très nombreuses
dispositions présentant différentes
améliorations et éléments de précision
du texte des commissions ont été adoptés
en séance
durant ces derniers jours nous espérons
dès lors que l'assemblée nationale sur à
se saisir de cette loi 3ds revue gourou
et et nous accompagner dans une démarche
qui se veut ambitieuse de
décentralisation en vue d'aboutir à une
réelle consolidation des libertés
locales
alors on regarde ces améliorations
substantielles apportées au projet de
loin notre vous notre groupe pardon
votera pour ce texte
et je vous remercie merci la parole est
au président claude malhuret pour le
groupe e les indépendants république et
territoires et pour sept minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
chaque révolution s'évapore en laissant
seulement derrière elle le dépôt d'une
nouvelle bureaucratie écrivait kafka
depuis plusieurs semaines vous expliqué
madame la ministre que ce texte n'est
pas une révolution c'est effectivement
ce que nous constatons je ne sais si
vous prendrez ce jugement comme un éloge
comme une critique il ya pour tout dire
un peu des deux mais on peut en tout cas
approuvé le fait que vous ayez éviter à
nos élus locaux et à nos concitoyens un
nouveau bouleversement il n'aurait pas
manqué d'apporter avec lui son lot de
complexité administrative dont les
collectivités territoriales souffre déjà
trop je tiens à saluer la qualité de nos
débats et remercier nos collègues
rapporteur malgré un contexte délicat et
dans un temps d'examen réduit notre
chambre substantiellement enrichit le
texte nous avons eu ainsi l'occasion de
voter plusieurs dispositions visant à
accroître la liberté des collectivités
territoriales le rétablissement
d'expérimentation de la recentralisation
du rsa proposé notamment par notre
groupe a été adopté par le sénat pour de
nombreux départements et pas seulement
celui de la seine saint denis
le rsa est une charge majeurs qui pèsent
considérablement sur les budgets
nous saluons également le renforcement
du rôle du département en matière d'
aides sociales et du poids des élus
locaux au sein des conseils
d'administration des ars qui permettront
aux collectivités d'avoir une meilleure
maîtrise de ses politiques nous
soutenons à cet égard les élargissements
du pouvoir règlementaire local porté par
le texte
même s'ils sont modestes le texte
comporte aussi un volet conséquent sur
le logement qui aurait d'ailleurs pu
faire l'objet d'un véhicule législatif à
part entière c'est l'un des sujets les
plus importants pour les élus locaux
confrontés en permanence aux complexités
de la loi sru à ses obligations à ces
seuils et à ces dérogations
les contrats de mixité sociale
apporteront des solutions adaptées aux
réalités
okal les communes qui ne respectent pas
les obligations en matière de logements
sociaux ne sont pas toujours des ennemis
de la mixité sociale
même si un certain mr le sont la plupart
font de leur mieux pour composer avec
les reee les règles très rigides de la
loi sru
ce projet de loi tel qu amendé par le
sénat apportera davantage de souplesse
et de liberté au maire pour adapter le
parc de logements aux objectifs fixés à
l'échelle nationale partageant cette
volonté de donner davantage de souplesse
et de liberté aux acteurs de terrain
notre collègue emmanuel capus a déposé
un amendement modifiant la loi sru il
vise à rendre plus progressive
l'entrée dans le régime d'obligations
concernant les seuils de logements
sociaux
notre chambre a compris tout l'intérêt
de ce dispositif pour les communes
elle a adopté ce texte apporte aussi de
la souplesse aux opérations de
revitalisation des territoires je veux
notamment citer l'accélération de la
procédure d'acquisition de biens sans
maîtres qui était attendu par les maires
de communes rurales de petites communes
au fil de son examen des prérogatives
des organismes fossiles solidaires ont
été renforcées par le texte est un point
important pour l'aménagement de nos
territoires
enfin grâce à l'adoption d'un amendement
déposé par notre collègue daniel
chassaing les communes touristiques
membres d'une communauté d'agglomération
qu'il souhaiterait pourront désormais
retrouver l'exercice de la compétence de
promotion du tourisme pour faciliter la
transition écologique dans nos
territoires il était nécessaire de
clarifier les compétences des régions et
des départements dans ce domaine
le maire se voit quant à lui confier la
possibilité de réglementer l'accès aux
espaces naturels protégés qui serait
menacée par une hyper fréquentation
ainsi que le souhaitait notre ancien
collègue jérôme bignon
nous saluons également la réforme de la
gouvernance de l'ademe opéré par le
texte le poids des territoires il sera
renforcé
ces territoires le sénat a tâché de les
libérer de leurs entraves
il est cependant arrivée kills entrave
lui-même
nous regrettons ainsi qu'un grand nombre
d'amendements n'ai pas pu être examinés
en raison d'une interprétation extensive
de l'article 40 de la constitution au
motif que les transferts de compétences
entre collectivités territoriales
créerait ou aggraverait une charge
publique
ils sont déclarées irrecevables il ya
plus de 35 ans le conseil
constitutionnel a rendu un arrêt qui
laisse effectivement penser que
l'article 46 opposerait l'idée que la
représentation nationale ne pourrait pas
passer proposé plus tôt par voie
d'amendement un transfert de compétences
entre collectivités territoriales est
pour le moins étonnante et les
parlementaires tiennent à leur liberté
d'amendements par ailleurs durant les 35
ans qui nous séparent de la décision du
conseil constitutionnel la démonstration
de la bonne gestion des deniers publics
par les collectivités locales a été
amplement fait l'état quant à lui à
démontrer linverse sur la même période
et se garde bien de s'appliquer une
règle similaire à celle de l'article 40
nous sommes également nombreux à
regretter l'application à géométrie
variable de l'autre faucheurs
d'amendements l'article 45 de la
constitution alors que le texte 3ds en
tient entend simplifier l'accès public
local les amendements de notre collègue
dany wattebled qui devait donner son
plein effet au principe selon lequel
silence vaut acceptation ont été
déclarés eux aussi irrecevable ce
mécanisme selon lequel silence gardé
pendant deux mois par l'administration
sur une demande vaut décision
d'acceptation est essentiel pour nos
concitoyens pour nos élus et pour nos
entrepreneurs
il est aujourd'hui vidée de sa substance
par une liste infinie de dérogation
alors que nous avions l'occasion de
remédier à cela en votant des
dispositions déjà adopté au sénat lors
de l'examen du texte accélération et
simplification de l'action publique
ces dispositions et délire est déclarée
irrecevable sans aucune explication nous
le regrettons vivement
le texte comporte néanmoins plusieurs
dispositions de simplification qu'il
convient de saluer et notamment celles
qui prévoient le renforcement des
échanges de données entre administration
et entre administrations et
collectivités territoriales nos élus ont
besoin de plus de simplicité mais aussi
de plus de soutien
le projet de loi il répond en faisant du
serema un outil au service de
l'ingénierie territoriale de l'état et
des collectivités
ces dernières seront désormais
représentés au sein de sa gouvernance
dans ce même esprit les chambres
régionales des comptes verront leurs
missions évoluer afin d'ajouter à leurs
fonctions de contrôle une assistance aux
collectivités territoriales dans
l'évaluation des politiques publiques au
total même si comme je lui ai expliqué
nous regrettons que certains nos
amendements que nous considérons
important n'est pas été prises en compte
et même si les changements apportés par
ce texte reste mesuré nous pensons qu'il
apporte des améliorations intéressantes
à l'activité des collectivités
territoriales le groupe des indépendants
votera donc majoritairement en faveur de
son adoption
la parole est à monsieur denis benarrosh
pour le groupe écologie solidarité
territoire pour sept minutes chers
collègues
présidente madame la ministre madame et
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues dire que la montagne a
accouché d'une souris ne serait pas le
plus approprié
au vu de l'évolution du texte après son
étude où c'est notre assemblée
alors ce serait une grosse souris bien
entendu en effet si le texte au départ
était port souvent imprécis quelquefois
et cohérent nous voici donc à l'arrivée
extrait du double d'articles et ce
malgré une grande libéralités très
souvent dénoncé dans cette assemblée
dans l'application de l'article carotte
une temporalité très complexe pour
assurer la sérénité des débats
je n'arrive toujours pas à comprendre le
choix du calendrier dans la foulée de la
loi qui m'a alors même que les élections
locales se déroulent et que dire d'autre
si les promesses du grand soir promis
lors du tour de france présidentielle
après la crise daisy les jeunes ne sont
pas au rendez vous parti d'un texte
n'apportant que de réponse parcellaire
aux enjeux si importants de
l'organisation territoriale de notre
pays nous arrivons à texte qui ne brille
pas par sa cohérence et par la cohérence
des positions retenu nos positions nous
écologistes sont stables depuis des
années du local au global la crise des
gilet jaune et la crise sanitaire dont
nous ne sommes toujours pas sortis
rappel et ont rappelé l'attachement des
français et du pays à un échelon local
plus souple plus agile pour répondre à
leurs attentes
et face à de nouveaux records
d'abstention électorale nous aurions pu
saisir l'occasion pour innover et
faciliter l'engagement des citoyens
encore eût-il fallu en avoir le temps
pourtant le texte tel qu'il résulte de
nos débats ne consacrent aucune nouvelle
décentralisation
pas plus qu'une mise en oeuvre d'une
différenciation efficace sans parler
d'une quelconque simplification en
décentralisant reconcentre house
recentralise aux dépôts centraux et sans
pouvoir répondre à la question des
citoyens comment ça marche
tout n'est que détail détails qui mis
côte à côte
après le vote du sénat
ne constitue en rien une oeuvre
pointilliste à l'asra
mais plutôt un patchwork est
déchiffrable aucune des propositions de
d'andrew pro forma un démocratie locale
le droit de pétition a été retenue pas
plus que le renforcement réel du pouvoir
réglementaire d'hubert pour protéger la
santé de ses citoyens ainsi que
l'environnement
pourquoi avoir autant teurs chers
collègues de la démocratie participative
il ne nie pas les lui et le pouvoir qui
est le sien mais via le renforcer
limiter le droit de pétition et rendre
optionnel sur d'inscription à l'ordre du
jour d'un conseil municipal est un
véritable couteau planté dans le dos du
pacte républicain
les élus sont responsables devant leurs
électeurs au travers des élections
certes mais empêcher une expression
libre vivante démocratique sur un sujet
porté par ces derniers au travers d'une
pétition
alors que notre devoir est de tout faire
pour permettre à d'autres démocraties de
sortir de la crise actuelle est une
faute
concernant le poids réglementaire du
maire je le répète je restais bailly de
thor d'hypocrisie du positionnement
majoritaire qui souhaiteraient donner à
pouvoir de veto aux maires pour
l'implantation des éoliennes structurant
la politique énergétique de toute une
région tout en lui refusant le droit de
réglementer les épandages de produits
phytosanitaires pour protéger les
habitants et les terres de son village
je ne reviendrai pas charitablement sur
les attaques et les accusations d'aghrib
aching sans aucun fragment que nous
subissons ici et là de temps en temps
nous écologistes
que dire aussi des possibilités ou
offertes par la nouvelle écriture de
modifier sous couvert de simplification
la portée des réglementations notamment
en matière dette sociale ou de
procédures d'urbanisme
j'ai l'occasion de l'argument t la
simplification ne doit pas être synonyme
de moins 10 ans essayons de rester
positif je salue le réveil de notre
assemblée suite aux débats de
commissions sur plusieurs points la
suppression des mesures faisant du ceser
une chambre soumises à des nominations
politiques voire poule
si sienne locales la possibilité
d'expérimentations de la
recentralisation du rsa ou une plus
grande démocratie sanitaire avec la
participation accrue des citoyens mais
aussi des élus le titre sur la
transition écologique soit tout comme la
loi climat d'ailleurs et la modification
de l'article 1 de la constitution non
aboutis n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux
quant à la remise sous préfectorales de
l'ademe une agence qui a fait ses
preuves dans le domaine de
l'environnement
cela laisse encore perplexe les
intéressés et toucher qui ont bénéficié
de son soutien
passée la surprise de voir réapparaître
volet logement
initialement prévue pour la loi dite
séparatisme nous avons constaté que ni
le gouvernement ni cette majorité
nota coeur de faire battre l'assignation
à résidence des populations précaires
qu'ils ont pourtant dénoncé les torts de
fois tout comme pour les éoliennes
la théorie du pas chez nous revient de
plus belle
comment justifier auprès de nos
concitoyens la possibilité pour les
communes de comptabiliser les casernes
militaires comme logements sociaux autre
exemple de cette lutte contre les
précaires plus que contre la précarité
le renforcement du contrôle des
allocataires du rsa ou le refus de
pérenniser l'encadrement des loyers
je glisserais un mot à la suite de mon
collègue stéphane leroux dullier sur les
dispositions concernant la métropole
d'aix marseille provence cher stéphane
tout comme vous j temps mais nous ne
sont pas encore arrivés au consensus
partis d'un constat consensuel lui sans
appel est partagé par tous de la
situation actuelle l'article 56 consacré
à cette métropole lire époque très
partiellement pour le moment voir dans
une ambition un peu trop partisane et on
ne permettant pas en 30 à la ville de
marseille d'être maîtresses de ces
politiques de proximité comme le sort
les autres communes des bouches du rhône
elle devra d'aurec retravailler
rapidement et sérieusement encore
plusieurs chers collègues si je
regrettais la timidité du gouvernement
qui n'aura pas saisi l'occasion et a
tardé à faire de réelles propositions
pour un nouveau pacte territorial
je regrette aussi que la majorité
sénatoriale est choisi de se contenter
de reprendre la vision partielle et
quelquefois partial de ces propositions
antérieures sans aucune ouverture ce
texte très étoffé sans vision réelle
structurantes sans cohérence dans le
rôle de chaque échelon ne résoudra pas
les problèmes d'organisation et de
coordination des communes des métropoles
et des régions c'est pourquoi
quoique cherves en défenseur d'une
décentralisation à la hauteur des
spécificités locales et d'une
différenciation synonyme d'efficacité et
pas de compétition et d'inégalités mais
aussi conscient des enjeux majeurs d'une
europe des régions
le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire ne votera pas ce texte est
votre à contre ce texte
merci merci la parole est un monsieur
ludovic et pour le groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants pour sept minutes chers
collègues dans la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
après trois semaines de travail et de
débats nourris la chambre des
territoires achevée hier soir l'examen
du projet de loi dit 3ds fruit d'une
longue gestation et de plusieurs mois de
concertation le texte porté par madame
la ministre jacqueline gourault que nous
saluons à nouveau pour l'immense travail
réalisé vient compléter les actes de
décentralisation qui n'hésitons pas à le
dire ont parfois l'effet des
imperfections et des carences dans
l'organisation actuelle de notre
millefeuille territorial en plus de
répondre aux attentes pragmatique qui
ont été exprimées à plusieurs occasions
le projet de loi 3ds marque un tournant
entre les relations entre l'état et les
collectivités
le texte s'appuie notamment sur la
contractualisation avec des outils
concrets pour permettre aux élus locaux
et aux collectivités territoriales
d'exercer les missions qui sont les
leurs avec plus de risques avec plus de
responsabilité et de singularité
ce texte se doit de tirer les leçons de
la crise sanitaire en confortant le rôle
des élus locaux et en améliorant la
collaboration avec les services
déconcentrés de l'état pour répondre à
ces objectifs le
gouvernement a proposé au sénat un texte
initial de 84 proposition qui repose sur
un juste équilibre entre les attentes
légitimes des territoires et des élus
locaux largement consulté tout au long
de la fabrication de ce texte sans
bouleversement des équilibres existants
après de nombreuses heures de débat il
faut noter le maintien des 84 articles
de départ avec quelques modifications du
sénat tels que la décentralisation des
routes au département en métropole et
aux régions qui le souhaitent la mise en
place différenciées et adaptées aux
réalités locales des objectifs de la loi
sru réforme qui n'avait jamais été
envisagée dans lé quinquennat précédent
depuis le vote de la loi en 2001 le
financement des établissements de santé
par les collectivités et leur capacité
de recruter des soignants pour leurs
centres de santé et même
l'expérimentation de la recentralisation
du rsa par l'état cela témoigne bien de
l'ecoute de la compréhension et de la
traduction législative des attentes
concrètes de nos élus dans le texte du
gouvernement
modifié par le sénat aussi dans une
ambiance consulte constructive et
sereine grâce à l'esprit de compromis de
nos rapporteur que je salue pour la
qualité du travail réalisé et pour le
plein exercice des libertés locales les
sénateurs ont enrichi le texte qui
compte aujourd'hui plus de 200 articles
le groupe air des pays à contribuer
comme d'autres groupes par lettre par
l'adoption de plusieurs amendements
proposés
je ne pourrais pas tous les énumérer ici
mais j'aimerais revenir sur ce qu'ils
ont fait consensus entre nos différents
groupes tout d'abord sur le titre
relatifs à la différenciation
territoriales
nous nous sommes entendus sur
l'extension du pouvoir réglementaire
locales afin de des pouvoirs développer
les libertés locales la suppression de
la définition de la composition du ceser
par délibération du conseil régional la
renforcement de la participation
citoyenne locale très attendu par nos
concitoyens
concernant le titre de sous la
transition écologique
après de nombreux débats nous sommes
tombés d'accord sur le transfert des
routes au département métropole et à
titre expérimental pour les régions
volontaires comme la région grand est
avec une version de compromis trouvé
entre les rapporteurs et le gouvernement
le transfert des petites lignes
ferroviaires de manière plus encadrées
ou ans
or les sanctions sur le domaine public
fluvial géré par les vnf les voies
navigables de france
ensuite sur le titre du logement et
urbanisme notre groupe a été
particulièrement actif afin de bien
rappeler les difficultés auxquelles se
heurtent nos élus locaux sur notamment
les atteintes des objectifs de la loi
sru
vous avez d'ailleurs bien voulu adopter
nos propositions sur l'augmentation des
catégories de dépenses déductibles du
prélèvement et ses rues et sur la
possibilité accordée aux communes
nouvelles de demander la conclusion d'un
contrat de mixité sociale
en dépit de quelques divergences
d'opinion sur des dispositions
techniques sur lesquels nous resterons
très attentifs dans le cadre des
navettes parlementaires sans dogmatisme
mais avec réalisme
nous nous sommes entendus sur la
suppression de la date butoir de 2025 ou
encore le rythme de rattrapage du
déficit de logements sociaux
différenciée selon les communes sru le
titre relatifs à la santé aura également
nourri de nombreux débats nous avons
toutefois converger vers une meilleure
représentation des élus locaux au sein
du conseil nistration des ars ou sur la
participation des usagers dans l'étude
conseils territoriaux de santé et dans
les contrats locaux de santé
toujours sur le titre santé vous avez
bien voulu adopter notre amendement
facilitant l'implantation des officines
de pharmacie à mayotte afin d'assurer un
maillage territorial en matière de santé
dans le domaine ultra marins les
échanges sur le titre u de l'outre-mer
ont été fructueux également ils ont
permis à notre groupe de proposer à la
haute-assemblée plusieurs dispositions
attendu par les territoires ultramarins
nous pouvons citer la mise à jour du
code de l'entrée et du séjour des
étrangers et du droit d'asile ceseda les
conditions de la prescription
acquisitive immobilière à mayotte
la dérogation au code de l'urbanisme
pour la construction de logements en
guyane le statut de clipperton ou encore
la composition du congrès des élus
départementaux et régionaux de la
guadeloupe la meilleure application du
service public numérique pour tous les
usagers avec l'application dites le nous
une fois principe qui prévoit que les
usagers n'est plus à un communiqué.les
communément les documents et
informations que l'administration leur a
déjà demandé par ailleurs la faculté des
collectivités de l2 le regroupement de
recourir au financement participatif
pour leurs investissements ou encore
l'extension dispositif de réunions par
visioconférence pour les conseils
départementaux
régionaux au conseil des syndicats
intercommunaux et aux syndicats mixtes
fermés font partie des mesures de
simplification qui ont été adoptés sur
les bancs du sénat
en outre chers collègues vous l'aurez
compris en prenant en compte ces
éléments le groupe r dpi votera en
faveur du pgl 3ds dans le droit fil des
actions menées depuis 2010 est en faveur
des élus locaux et des collectivités
nous émettons toutefois plusieurs
réserves sur certaines dispositions
adoptées par le sénat
si certains ont souhaité rejouer le
match de la loi engagement à proximité
ou du projet de loi climat et résilience
nous ne pouvons pas revenir sur les
équilibres qui ont pu être trouvé comme
nous l'avions indiqué au début d'examen
à titre d'exemple le transfert de la
compétence eau et assainissement ou paix
et lui a le pci les compétences à la
carte pour les opci les capacités
d'intervention pour les départements
dans le domaine économique
le durcissement des conditions d'accès
dans la prestation du rsa ou encore
l'obligation d'un avis conforme du
conseil municipal pour les projets
d'installation d'éoliennes dont sur des
propositions que nous pouvons entendre
mais qui ne crée pas à ce jour aucun
consensus et que notre groupe ne partage
pas le texte poursuivra son examen à
l'assemblée nationale et nous faisons le
voeu sincère que les débats constructifs
et bienveillant que nous avons eues
auxerre de cette haute assemblée
ainsi que l'esprit de compromis que nous
avons eues avec lourd à porter et qui
ont guidé le sénat le gouvernement se
poursuivent je vous remercie
la parole est à même la présidente
nathalie delattre a pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour sept minutes
chers collègues
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame et monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous achevons quinze
jours d'examen d'un projet de loi dans
les débats furent finalement plus
engagés qu'attendu même s'ils furent
toutefois sous tendu par la fatigue d'un
marathon législatif particulièrement
intense et que nous avons subies cette
année
à cela s'ajoute l'amer constat quasi
unanimement souligné lors de la
discussion générale de voir combien ce
texte en arrivant sur nos pupitres nous
apparaît éloigné de son ambition
initiale et des fortes attentes qu'il
suscitait de la part des collectivités
d'autant plus que son examen suite
quelques jours un scrutin marqué par une
abstention record et préoccupante
facettes cet horizon encombré le sénat a
toutefois su remonter toute la
profondeur des questions locales
nos échanges ont traduit combien la vie
nos territoires étaient riches qu'ils
s'y jouait des questions majeures de la
vie de notre nation
je pense par exemple à nos discussions
autour de l'article 17 et de
l'application de la loi sru certains ont
fait part de leur crainte que ce projet
de loi dénature l'esprit initial de la
loi au motif de davantage de souplesse
d'autres ont pu souligner au contraire
qu'à défaut de souplesse et objectifs de
la loi sru ne serait jamais atteint car
parfois irréalisable néanmoins au delà
des positions soutenues
nous nous accordons a regretté qu'un tel
sujet ne soit pas l'objet d'une
discussion à part entière plutôt que de
traiter entre le transfert des
compétences voirie et la réforme de la
gouvernance des ars au cours des débats
certaines mesures adoptées ont révélé
des clivages profonds mettant là aussi
en lumière toute l'importance de la vie
politique locale
ce fut par exemple le cas à propos de
cette disposition adoptée en commission
des lois qui permet au département de
décider de priver du rsa les personnes
disposant d'une épargne trop importante
une majorité des membres du rds doute
que cette mesure soit la plus à même de
lutter efficacement contre les abus de
notre système de solidarité
cela étant nonobstant ces premières
considération je veux saluer le travail
du
senna au premier rang desquels celui de
nos rapporteur notre assemblée a su
s'approprier pleinement un texte au
sujet duquel nous avions d'abord fait
part de notre déception et a su garder
sa cohérence
c'est lequel la réintroduction d'un
droit à l'erreur pour les collectivités
locales qui hélas peine toujours à vous
convaincre madame la ministre
le groupe rdse tenait également à saluer
la transposition dans ce texte de la
proposition de loi visant à moderniser
et faciliter la procédure
d'expropriation de biens en état
d'abandon manifeste largement adopté au
sénat le 14 avril dernier avec un avis
favorable du gouvernement
ces dispositions devraient permettre de
mieux soutenir la revitalisation nos
communes face au problème croissant de
la soude optimisation des biens
immobiliers et des terrains abandonnés
par leurs propriétaires
malgré tout je crains que nous n'ayons
pas pleinement su rattraper les défauts
les insuffisances initialement constatés
dans le volet de la différenciation et
cela malgré les améliorations faites au
cours de cet examen
il se pose toujours la question de la
portée réelle de ce principe
notamment au regard des moyens d'autant
que la différenciation porte en elle
même un risque celui d'une inégalité
territoriale qui se creuserait encore
davantage avec le temps si nous voulons
que ce nouveau souffle territoriale soit
porteur d'un meilleur avenir pour nos
collectivités
il faudra se montrer particulièrement
vigilants dans les années à venir
pour éviter toute forme de dérive et de
particularismes locaux au détriment des
territoires moins favorisés mais
difficile de rejeter ce texte à ce motif
dont il est fait d'un ensemble de
dispositions diverses qui comporte de
bonnes mesures et que le sénat aura
introduit pour beaucoup parmi ces
améliorations je pense à l'article
ajouté suite à l'adoption de
l'amendement de notre collègue jean yves
brooks permettant aux communes
touristiques membres d'une communauté
d'agglomération de retrouver l'exercice
de la compétence promotion du tourisme
nos débats nous aurons aussi éviter de
commettre certaines erreurs comme
s'agissant de la modification de la
composition des ceser amendement que je
portais au nom de mon groupe
j'aimerais aussi revenir sur la non
suppression de l'article 7 du projet qui
vise à instituer une expérimentation
permettant aux régions d'exercer la
compétence d'aménagement
et de gestion des routes nationales et
autoroutes non concédées nous avons dit
combien ont regardé cette disposition
nous interroger quant à la lisibilité
des compétences des collectivités en
matière de voirie routière
d'autant que les départements sont
connues et reconnues pour l'exploitation
de leur domaine routier alors que les
régions sont loin de disposer de telles
compétences aussi je regrette que cet
art clip tic n'est finalement pas été
supprimée à la faveur d'un second vote
à minuit et demi hier soir alors que la
maman que je portais avait été adopté
dans la semaine pour l'essentiel notre
groupe demeure attaché aux communes et
aux départements et ne souhaite pas
privilégiée a laissé les échelons inter
communaux et régionaux
nous y voyons un risque d'éloignement
des organes de décision des territoires
à l'image de ce que nous avons défendues
au sujet de la réforme des agences de
l'eau de cette même manière certains
points suscitent encore d'importantes
interrogations notamment concernant
l'ademe dont nous ne comprenons pas
malgré les premières réponses apportées
par la commission le sens où du moins
l'intérêt de la réforme
en dernier lieu je voudrais dire un mot
de ce qui n'a pas été examinée dans ce
texte
un exemple un exemple nous a
particulièrement affecté durant ces deux
semaines nous avons souvent abordé la
question des communes de montagne
ce qui n'a rien de surprenant dans un
texte prenant la différenciation
juridique des territoires mais
étonnamment certains aspects n'ont pas
pu être développées au motif
d'irrecevabilité parfois peu
compréhensible notre goal collègues
ghislaine quand elle en aura fait part
durant les débats en indiquant regretté
que ne puisse être discuté son
amendement concernant le droit
d'urbanisme et les risques d'une double
application des lois littoral et
montagne
dans ce même esprit je pense également à
l'amendement qu aurait souhaité porter
notre collègue andré guiol visant à
repenser les conséquences de la
suppression des zones
nb dans les règlements locaux
d'urbanisme l'ambitieux simplification
ray justifier que ces sujets soient au
moins abords des tentes ils sont l'objet
pour nos communes de difficultés au
quotidien
aussi au regard de ces éléments vous
comprendrez que le groupe rdse ne
tiendra pas une position unanime et
chacun de ses membres conservera comme
il est de principe sa pleine liberté de
vote avec toutefois une majorité
vote en faveur de ce texte merci merci
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
il va être procédé dans les conditions
prévues par l'article 56 de règlement au
scrutin public ordinaire sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi relatif à la
différenciation la décentralisation la
déconcentration et portant diverses
mesures de simplification de l'action
publique locale
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
minutes
le scrutin est ouvert
sun ne demanda à voter le scrutin est
clos
merci voici le résultat du scrutin
numéro 161 sur l'ensemble du texte
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifiée à la présidence nombre de
votants 345 nombre de pros suffrages
exprimés 334 pour l'adoption 242 contre
92 le sénat a adopté la fin la parole
est à madame jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
nous arrivons au terme de ces débats
très riches de ces dix journées et nuits
passées ensemble avec plus de mille
amendements examinés en séance
je tenais à remercier la commission des
lois et son président françois noël
buffet et bien sûr ses rapporteurs
françoise gatel et mathieu darnaud
qu'ils ont accompli leur mission avec
conviction remercier également les
rapporteurs dominique estrosi sassone à
la mi longs et daniel guéret pour leur
apport décisif et leur engagement pour
défendre ce texte
et puis je tenais bien sûr à vous
remercier madame la présidente ainsi que
l'ensemble de vos collègues qui ont
présidé pendant ces dix jours de séance
pour l'exigence d'efficacité et de
sérénité des débats que vous avez porté
je tiens à souligner cet état d'esprit
constructif dans lequel nous avons
collectivement le vrai et que nous
partageons depuis de nombreux mois
je vous le disais le 7 juillet dernier
en ouverture de nos débats il s'agit
d'un texte de confiance de confiance
vis-à-vis des élus locaux mais aussi de
confiance vis-à-vis du sénat qui a fait
preuve de responsabilité et qui a le
plus souvent converger
avec le gouvernement n'en déplaise à
ceux qui veulent réécrire l'histoire et
faire passer le récit d'une
confrontation
il n'en a rien été il nous reste bien
sûr des divergences c'est normal
notamment sur l'intercommunalité ça a
été souligné à l'instant mais je suis
sûr qu'une position d' équilibre entre
les besoins de proximité et la nécessité
de mutualisation et de mise en commun
sera être trouvée à la faveur de la
navette mais je retiens aussi qu'un
grand nombre de mesures importantes ont
été adoptées et les différents orateurs
qui sont passés avant moi l'ont dit je
ne vais pas être exhaustive mais je
voudrais retenir l'extension du pouvoir
réglementaire locale
la pérennisation de la loi sru et sa
mise en oeuvre différencier via le
contrat de mixité sociale
le transfert des routes départementales
et des routes nationales pardon aux
départements et l'expérimentation en
direction des régions pour les régions
volontaires la capacité pour les
collectivités à financer des
établissement de santé et à recruter des
soignants bien sûr l'expérimentation de
la recentralisation du rsa ou encore le
renforcement des pouvoirs des
collectivités locales pour mettre en
oeuvre concrètement la transition
écologique sur leur territoire je ne
serai pas plus longue
toutes ces mesures portent des avancées
concrètes au bénéfice des territoires et
de nos concitoyens je vous remercie à
nouveau toutes et tous pour votre
investissement et je remercie bien sûr
ce qui d'entre vous ont voté en faveur
du texte qui répond aux besoins concrets
des territoires je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]